FILE I.
AB TWENTY FIVE TEN MISTER MAYOR
SUTURES BEEN PULLED BY THE
COMMITTEE.
AND WHAT AND WHAT THAT WILL
START WITH ITEM SEVEN AB TWENTY
NINE THIRTY ADMISSIBLE.
THINK.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR VICE CHAIR
COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE
TO THANK GOD OF THE CHAIR AND
HER STAFF FOR THEIR ATTENTION TO
THIS BILL AND. THERE'S AN
AMENDMENT RECOMMENDATION AND
COMMENT SEE THAT WE WILL WORK
WITH COMMITTEE TO INCORPORATE
INTO THE. INTO THE BILL TODAY
I'M PRESENTING MOVED TO BILL AB
TWENTY NINE THIRTY EIGHT MUCH OF
WOULD ALLOW THE CITY OF SANTA
MONICA TWO YEARS TO ALIGN AND
ADJUST THEIR. TAX ELECTION TO
BETTER MATCH.
TAX COLLECTIONS OF OTHER BIKE
SHARE SYSTEMS AND LA COUNTY.
BUT SHARE AS SITE I'M SURE YOU
ALL KNOW HAS BECOME A POPULAR
STRATEGY FOR ENCOURAGING ACTIVE
TRANSPORTATION DECREASING
VEHICLE TRIPS AND HELPING CITIES
COUNTIES AND REGIONAL AGENCIES
ACHIEVE LOCAL AND STATE.
TRANSPORTATION AND EMISSION
REDUCTION GOALS.
SANTA MONICA LAUNCHED LA
COUNTY'S FIRST BIKESHARE SYSTEM
IN TWENTY FIFTEEN AND TODAY
SERVES OVER EIGHTY THOUSAND
ACTIVE USERS USERS SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF THOSE YEARS BEING LA
COUNTY RESIDENTS SANTA MONICA
AND MANY OTHER CITIES IN LA
COUNTY HAVE CREATED. CITY
OPERATED BY CHAIR SYSTEMS THAT
ARE WORKING TO INTEGRATE AND
REGIONAL ALLIES THEIR PROGRAMS
WHICH IN AN AREA LIKE A LA
COUNTY CAN IMAGINE IS. VERY
COMPLICATED A REGIONAL SYSTEM
WOULD PROVIDE AN EXPANDED SYSTEM
TO INCREASE ACCESS IMPROVE
SERVICE AND ENCOURAGE MORE
PEOPLE. TO BIKE IN THEIR
COMMUTES BETWEEN CITIES ONE
BARRIER REACH ALLIES IN THE BIKE
SHARE SYSTEM IS BEEN THAT
DIFFERENCES IN TAX COLLECTIONS
BETWEEN THE CITIES. AND TO SERVE
THIS BILL SEEKS TO REMEDY THAT
FOR SANTA MONICA THE DIFFERENCES
IN TAX COLLECTIONS MAKE IT
IMPOSSIBLE. TO USE INTEGRATED
SOFTWARE FOR A OF VARIOUS
BIKESHARE SYSTEMS THAT CURRENTLY
EXIST AND MIGHT EXIST IN THE
FUTURE.
AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY EIGHT
REMOVED THIS BARRIER AND BY
EXTENSION HELPS TO INCREASE.
BIKE USE IN LA COUNTY WITH ME I
HAVE HOMELESS ANIMAL
REPRESENTING THE. CITY OF SANTA
MONICA TO SPEAK MORE ABOUT THE
BILL AN ANSWER TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS.
GOOD AFTERNOON MR VICE CHAIR
MEMBERS MONTHS AMMAN BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SANTA MONICA I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS IN THE PROPOSED
AMENDMENT. AS NOTED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AND BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM THIS BILL
IS CRITICAL IN FACILITATING THE
INTEGRATION OF ST MONICA'S
POPULAR BREEZE BIKESHARE
PROGRAM.
WITH SIMILAR BIKESHARE PROGRAMS
IN NEIGHBORING CITIES AND WITH
UCLA. THE BREEZE BIKESHARE
PROGRAM WAS IMPLEMENTED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN AND AT THE TIME
WE CHOSE TO PAY USE TAX ON THE
RENTAL RECEIPTS THE BIKES.
HOWEVER IT NOW THAT OTHER CITIES
IN OUR REGION ARE ATTEMPTING TO
IMPLEMENT A REGIONAL BIKESHARE
SYSTEM THE CITY HAS STYMIED DUE
TO OUR TAX ELECTION WHICH IS
DIFFERENT AND THE ELECTION
CHOSEN BY THE OTHER CITIES THAT
PAID THE SALES TAX WHEN THEY
PURCHASE THEIR BICYCLES.
PROVIDING A PERSPECTIVE USE TAX
EXEMPTION ON THE BY SCHOOLS
PURCHASE IN TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN
IT WILL ALLOW THE BREEZE BIKES
TO BE INTEGRATED WITH OTHER
SYSTEMS. AND ALSO ALLOW US TO
ADD A SECOND GROUPOF TAX PAID
BIKES INTO SECULAR NATION.
ORIGINAL BIKESHARE PROGRAM WILL
LEAD TO INCREASED USE OF THESE
BIKES AS WELL AS REDUCE VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED AND REDUCE
EMISSIONS. FOR THESE REASONS THE
CITY OF SAN MONICA SPONSORING
THIS MEASURE AND RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU.
OTHER INNOCENTS FOR.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE.
AND YOU AGREED TO BE AMENDMENTS
TO DELETE SECTION A AND B. M.
PROVIDE A PERSPECTIVE USE TAX
EXEMPTION FOR THE FIVE HUNDRED
BICYCLES PURCHASED IN TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN CORRECT. YES
THEY DO ALRIGHT FANTASTIC.
ANY COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
QUESTIONS COMMENTS SEEN NO
ENJOYED CLOSE.
THANK A MANAGER GOOD AFTERNOON
HIGH I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WELL WE HAD WE ON OF A QUORUM WE
DON'T HARM SO.
THE RECOMMENDATION WILL BE DO
PASS BUT WE WILL GET. WE WILL
TAKE A VOTE WILL HAVE COURT
THANK YOU.
DO PASS AS AMENDED.
BUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTY.
TO HARPER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
OPEN.
ABSOLUTELY.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I'M HERE
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN THIRTY WHICH WILL PROHIBIT
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD OR ANY
OTHER PUBLIC OR PRIVATE ENTITY
FROM CONDUCTING A WAGE
GARNISHMENT. OR BANK LEVY FOR
THE COLLECTION OF UNPAID TOLLS
OR TWELVE ASIAN PENALTIES.
CALIFORNIANS OFTEN USED HOLE
ROADS OR BRIDGES TO COMMUTE TO
WORK OR EVEN TRAVEL.
THEY THE PAY THE TOLL WITH CASH
OR HAVE A TOLL ACCOUNT WITH THE
FAST TRACK WORKS PRESS ACCOUNT
RATHER MEASURE.
WHEN INDIVIDUALS FAILED TO PAY A
TOLL THEIR SUBJECT TO PENALTIES
THESE PENALTIES CAN RANGE FROM
ONLY TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS.
FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS PER
PENALTIES IN TWENTY FIFTEEN TOLL
AGENCIES WORTH AUTHORIZED TO
CONDUCT WAGING BANK LEVEES
THROUGH THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD
AGAINST INDIVIDUALS WHO FAIL TO
PAY THEIR TOLL VIOLATIONS.
IN ADDITION PENALTY FEES
CONTINUE TO ACCRUE ON UNPAID
BALANCES WELL WAGING BANK LEVEES
ARE IN EFFECT.
EVEN THOUGH THE FRANCHISE TAX
BOARD ONLY GETS INVOLVED AFTER A
PERSON IS EXHAUSTED THE APPEALS
PROCESS. TO OVERTURN PULL
VIOLATIONS ALL FINES AND
PENALTIES HAVE TO BE PAID UP
FRONT BEFORE THAT PROCESS CAN
EVEN BEGIN.
IF SOMEONE HAS TEN THOUSAND
DOLLARS AND PULL VIOLATIONS AND
UNPAID. AND ADDITIONAL PENALTIES
IT IS HIGHLY UNLIKELY HIGHLY
LIKELY THAT THEY CANNOT AFFORD
TO FILE AN APPEAL.
NOT APPEALING THE TOLL
VIOLATIONS CAN LEAD TO WAGE
GARNISHMENT
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD HAS THE
AUTHORITY TO CONDUCT WAGE CAR
CARTMAN'S FOR UP TO TWENTY FIVE
PERCENT. OF AN INDIVIDUAL'S
PAYCHECK.
THEY HAVE THE ABILITY TO GARNISH
THE WAGES OF A DEBTOR SPOUTS IS
WELL. THAT MEANS A CALIFORNIA
FAMILIES AT RISK TO HAVE ONE
QUARTER OF THEIR MONTHLY INCOME
TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM.
THIS HURTS THEIR ABILITY TO KEEP
FOOD ON THE TABLE CLOTHES ON
THEIR BACKS ON A ROOF OVER THEIR
HEAD.
NUMEROUS RESIDENTS IN ORANGE
COUNTY OF RECEIVED MASSIVE FINES
FOR TOLL VIOLATIONS IN THESE
INCLUDE BRING ON PABLO GONZALEZ.
WHO FAILED TO PAY SIXTY DOLLARS
AND FOURTEEN CENTS AND TOLLS BUT
THEY WERE BILLED SEVENTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DOLLARS IN PENALTIES?
STEPHANIE AND BRIAN YOUNG.
RACKED UP FIVE HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY DOLLARS IN UNPAID TOLLS
AFTER CREDIT CARD LINK TO THEIR
TRANSPONDER ACCOUNT EXPIRED BUT
THEY PASTE FACED FIFTY THREE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY
DOLLARS IN FINES.
AND SHERRY HUTTON WHO IS UNAWARE
THAT HER FAST TRACK PASSED WAS
NO LONGER LINKED TO OUR BANK
ACCOUNT. HER PENALTIES AND LATE
FEES ADDED UP TO MORE THAN FORTY
NINE THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CURLY TOLL AGENCIES HAVE THE
ABILITY TO IMPOSE LESS INTRUSIVE
MEANS OF COLLECTING UNPAID TOLL
OF ASIAN PENALTIES.
THESE INCLUDE PLACING HOLD ON
THE VEHICLE'S REGISTRATION
OBTAINING A CIVIL JUDGMENT
CONTRACTING WITH COLLECTION
AGENCIES DEDUCTING FROM A TAX
REFUND OR PLACING A LIEN ON THE
VEHICLE ITSELF.
WITH CALIFORNIA BEING ONE OF THE
MOST EXPENSIVE STATES TO LIVE
AND RESIDENTS CANNOT AFFORD.
THEIR EARNED INCOME TO BE
FORCIBLY TAKEN AWAY FROM THEM
BECAUSE OF JUST AN HONEST
MISTAKE.
THIS BILL WOULD PROTECT
CALIFORNIANS FROM BEING PUSHED
INTO POVERTY BECAUSE OF MINOR
PULL VIOLATIONS
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY SEVEN THIRTY. IS JOSH
BARNETT REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BUS ASSOCIATION.
WHO IS IN SUPPORT?
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS JOSH PAWNEE
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA BUS
ASSOCIATION. THE ASSOCIATION
TOOK A LOOK AT THIS AND THERE
HAVE BEEN PROBLEMS THAT THEIR
DRIVERS EIGHTY PLUS COMPANIES
HAVE HAD.
WITH TOLD.
ISSUES THAT THIS AND OTHER TOOL
ISSUES.
SO THAT THEY WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT.
FOR THIS MEASURE AYE AS JUST A
PLAIN AND SIMPLE PIECE OF COMMON
SENSE IT SHOULD BE IN LAW. ARE
SO THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SPORT.
WHEN THIS IS IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
DUCTWORK.
ARM.
SO IN.
YOU'VE CONVINCED ME TO VOTE I
ON THE BILL THANK YOU.
BUT WHAT IT WHAT BOTHERS ME IS
HOW FROM A SIMPLE ERROR LIKE
YEAH EXPIRATION OF A CREDIT CARD
YOU MISS THE NOTIFICATION.
THAT THEY CAN END UP FINDING YOU
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS.
I THINK MAYBE THAT'S THE BASIS
OF THE PROBLEM.
AND I THINK IT SOME POINT WE
OUGHT TO BE ADDRESSING THAT I
MEAN THESE THESE.
.
THAT JUST SEEMS EXCESSIVE.
I WOULD AGREE AND I THINK THAT
OF VERY OFTEN.
TOLL ROADS AND TOLL BRIDGES ARE
THE WAY TO BE ABLE TO PROVIDE
IMPORTANT INFRASTRUCTURE.
THE CHALLENGE IS HOW DO WE GET
A SITUATION WHERE SOMETHING LIKE
THIS GETS OUT OF CONTROL. AND
THE SPECIFICS OF THIS BILL.
AT LEAST THE WAGE GARNISHMENT
WHICH I THINK IS THE MOST
INTRUSIVE WAY TO BE ABLE YEAH.
SO ANYWAY YES I'LL BE VOTING FOR
THE BILL.
YOU DID NEXT ON PRESENTATION
THAT I WASN'T SURE TO START.
SOMETIMES YOU PRESENTATION DOES
MAKE A DIFFERENCE THANK YOU.
BUT AGAIN IF YOU WANT TO BRING
A BILL NEXT YEAR. THAT GOES TO
THE QUESTION OF WHY THESE
AUTHORITY SHOULD BE ABLE TO TAKE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS IN.
FINDS ARE I'D BE VERY
INTERESTED THANK YOU THANK YOU.
MR GRAY.
ECHO MY COLLEAGUE'S COMMENTS A.
MY.
FIRST A BLUSH LOOK THIS WAS WHAT
WAS I DID INTEND TO SUPPORT IT.
AFTER LISTENING TO YOUR
PRESENTATION I'M MORE INCLINED
TO VOTE IN FAVOR OF ABSENT
QUESTION HAVE YOU EXPLORED THAT
AS YOU ALL THROUGH THE MEASURE.
IN CAPPING THE FEES SOME
REASONABLE. AMOUNT.
I. WOULD I HAD LOOKED AT THAT IT
WASN'T THE CAPPING THE FEES
INITIALLY BUT AS I SAID THAT'S.
CERTAINLY.
VERY IMPORTANT DIED AND AND I
THINK AMERICA PULLED LA.
A SUGGESTION ABOUT WHAT WE'RE
LOOKING TO DO HERE WAS
SPECIFICALLY THE INVOLVEMENT OF
THE FRANCHISE TAX BOARD AND THE
LOW WAGE GARNISHMENT DIE ASPECT
OF IT. AYE BECAUSE THEY SAY SAID
FOR PEOPLE WHO ARE ARE NOT OF
THE SIGNIFICANT MEANS THAT'S
QUITE POSSIBLY AMONG THE MOST
DEVASTATING WAYS TO BE ABLE TO
TACKLE THE ISSUE.
ONE DE ELISE'S ANALYSIS SAYS HER
THE EXISTING.
LAW ALLOWS THEM TO TAKE THAT
ACTION FOR A WHOLE HOST RENDON
CHANGED WE TRANSFER SEES.
LICENSE FEES USE TAXES PARDON
PANEL THERE'S ABOUT TO HAPPEN TO
YOU LOOK LATER WHICH I THINK
THERE ARE MUCH BETTER TO USE
THAN THE FRANCHISE.
BUT YOU'RE WILLING TO LOOK AT
CAPPING.
FEES GOING FORWARD EVEN IN THIS
BILL.
I'D BE.
BUT. I WOULD CERTAINLY I
CONSIDER.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE WHICH ELECT
CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION.
MORE MORE DRIVER SEIZING TOLL
ACCOUNTS TO PAY FOR THEIR
COMMUTES AND THE TOLL ROADS AND
BRIDGES SINCE DRIVERS MAY NOT BE
AWARE THAT THE CREDIT CARDS
CONNECTED TO ACCOUNT EXPIRES.
VIOLATION SOMETIMES OCCUR BY
THIS MINOR VIOLATION SHOULD NOT
TO. BE SOMETHING SO DEVASTATING
TO OUR FAMILY.
FAMILY'S INCOME THEIR JOB BY IN
THEIR WAY OF LIFE I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM BUT I
WILL MAKE A COMMENT MYSELF AND
I'M SIMILAR TO.
DOCTOR QUIRK AND MISTER GRAY DO.
RECOGNIZE THE PROBLEM HOWEVER.
IT'S NOT JUST HOLES PARKING HAS
THE SAME ISSUES AS WELL SO IN MY
OPINION I THINK THEY'RE PROBABLY
WAY TO FACILITATE A MORE ELEGANT
SOLUTION TO THIS ISSUE. SO FOR
THAT REASON I'M A NUN
RECOMMENDATION WHEN WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM. OF WILLIAM FORMAL TAKE
VOTE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR I APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION OF ALL THE MEMBERS
.
I AM NUMBER FOUR AB TWENTY SIX
SIXTY THREE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN
.
JW YES THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS I'M HAPPY TO ACCEPT THE
AMENDMENTS THAT ALIGN THE BILL
WITH PROVISIONS IN PLACE FOR
DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS REGISTERED
AT THE STATE LEVEL. AND I WANT
TO THANK YOU AND YOUR STAFF FOR
YOUR HELP.
PRIOR TO TWO THOUSAND SIX A
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP BETWEEN
DOMESTIC PARTNERS WAS NOT
ELIGIBLE FOR THE SAME PROPERTY
TAX EXCLUSION THAT APPLY TO
MARRIED COUPLES.
THANKFULLY SUBSEQUENT
LEGISLATION FIX A DISCREPANCY
FOR DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
REGISTER AT THE STATE LEVEL.
HOWEVER FOR COUPLES WOULD
REGISTER THE DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR LOCAL
COUNTY OR CITY AND NOT AT THE
STATE LEVEL THE SAME EXCLUSION
HAS NOT BEEN AVAILABLE. WITH THE
AMENDMENTS BEFORE YOU TODAY AB
TWO SIX SIX THREE WILL CREATE
PARITY IN THE LAW FOR ALL
REGISTERED DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
REGARDLESS OF WHERE THEY'RE
ORIGINALLY REGISTERED.
SPECIFICALLY A PROPERTY THAT WAS
REASSESSED AS A RESULT OF A
TRANSFER BETWEEN REGISTERED
DOMESTIC PARTNERS BETWEEN
JANUARY TWO THOUSAND AND JUNE
TWENTY SIXTH TWO THOUSAND
FIFTEEN. CAN RECEIVED A REVERSAL
OF THAT REASSESSMENT WITH AN
APPLICATION TO THE COUNTY
ASSESSOR.
THE PROCESS WILL BE ALIGNED WITH
WHAT'S CURRENTLY IN PLACE FOR
OTHER DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS
INCLUDING THE INFORMATION
REQUIRED FOR THE APPLICATION.
NO ONE SHOULD RISK LOSING THEIR
HOME AS A RESULT OF THE DEATH OF
THIS PART OF THEIR PARTNER. AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE CLOSES IN
UNINTENDED LOOPHOLE ENSURES THAT
ALL COUPLES HAVE EQUAL ACCESS TO
BENEFITS INCLUDING TAX RELIEF.
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR YOUR HELP
REFINING THE BILL I'VE
REPRESENTATIVES FROM THE
SPONSORS OF AB TWENTY I TWO SIX
SIX THREE. THE LA COUNTY
ASSESSOR'S OFFICE AND EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA HERE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT AND TO ANSWER ANY
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS MAY HAVE. I
REQUEST REALLY HOUSE FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR BURKE AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
CHRISTINA NGUYEN AND I'M THE
ASSESSOR SACRAMENTO COUNTY. I'M
HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF AB TWO
SIX SIX THREE AND TO SPEAK ON
BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUE ASSESSOR
JEFF PRAYING.
OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
ALSO JOINING IN SPONSORSHIP OF
THIS LEGISLATION IS ASSESSOR
CARMEN CHIU OF SAN FRANCISCO.
THE PROBLEM FOR DOMESTIC
PARTNERS WHO REGISTERED WITH THE
LOCAL JURISDICTION AND NOT THE
STATE.
THEY ARE NOT ABLE TO UTILIZE THE
EXCLUSION FROM REASSESSMENT OF
THEIR PROPERTY BASED UPON A
CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP.
FOR SOME OF THESE LOCAL REGISTER
PARTNERS THEIR PROPERTY WAS
REVALUED RESULTING IN A INCREASE
IN PROERTY TAXES.
ASSESSORS LACK AUTHORITY TO
REVERSE THE INCREASE IN VALUE
AND THERE IS NO RECOURSE TO
PROVIDE A REFUND OF THE
OVERPAYMENT THAT OCCURRED AS A
RESULT OF THE REASSESSMENT.
THE SOLUTION. AB TWO SIX SIX
THREE CREATES A LOCAL DOMESTIC
PARTNERSHIPS AND GRANTS TO THOSE
PARTNERS OF THE SAME EXCLUSION.
FROM A CHANGE IN OWNERSHIP ASK
OUT PROVIDED TO STATE REGISTERED
DOMESTIC PARTNERS AND TO MARRIED
COUPLES.
THIS IS A MATTER OF EQUALITY.
AND FAIRNESS
TO ASSURE THAT LOCAL REGISTER
DOMESTIC PARTNERS HAVE THE SAME
ACCESS
TO THE EXCLUSION FROM A CHANGE
IN OWNERSHIP.
AND TO CREATE AN AMNESTY IF YOU
WILL TO SEEK REVERSAL OF THE
REASSESSMENT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE ROY
ASHBURN FROM THE OFFICE OF. LOS
ANGELES ESTHER JEFF PRANG IN
SUPPORT OF THE MEASURE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS JOE MICHAEL
FOR EQUALITY CALIFORNIA WE'RE
PROUD TO BE A CO SPONSOR OF THIS
BILL AND WE'RE VERY GRATEFUL FOR
THAT COLLABORATION HERE WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN AND
WITH THE ASSESSOR'S OFFICES IN
VARIOUS PARTS OF THE STATE. I
JUST WANTED TO HIGHLIGHT THAT
ULTIMATELY THIS IS REALLY ABOUT
ENSURING THAT PARTNERS WHO HE
AND I EITHER HAD A VERY
DIFFICULT TIME MAINTAINING THEIR
HOME.
AFTER THE DEATH OF THEIR
PARTNER OR PERHAPS EVEN LOST
THEIR HOME AFTER THE DEATH OF
THEIR PARTNER AS A RESULT OF NOT
HAVING A REGISTRATION BE I'M AT
THE STATE LEVEL. I CAN HAVE SOME
SORT OF.
AT REIMBURSEMENT FOR THAT ARE
RIGHT GUY RECONCILIATION TO
RECOVER ON AT LEAST A LITTLE BIT
OF WHAT THEY MIGHT HAVE LOST AND
I'M WHAT THEY SHOULD NOT HAVE
HAD TO PAY FRANKLY. I'M IF THE
EXCLUSION HAD APPLIED TO THEM
I'M AND PART OF WHAT THIS IS
ABOUT IS THAT PRIOR TO. THE
AFFIRMATION OF THE FREEDOM TO
MARRY AND CALIFORNIAAND I AT
THE FEDERAL LEVEL RELATIONSHIP
RECOGNITION FOR SAME SEX COUPLES
WITH COMPLEX AND FOR A NUMBER OF
YEARS SAME SEX COUPLES WERE
OFTEN UNSURE ABOUT WHERE AND HOW
THEY COULD REGISTER. AS DOMESTIC
PARTNERS AND WHAT PROTECTIONS
WOULD COME WITHOUT REGISTRATION
AND WHAT WHICH WOULD NOT AYE SO
DURING THAT TIME OF CONFUSION
AND UNCERTAINTY THAT THE BILL
COVERS I'M SAME SEX COUPLES WHO
WERE ONLY REGISTERED AT THAT
LOCAL LEVEL AND NOT WITH THE
STATE. WERE VULNERABLE TO THIS
REASSESSMENT ON THE DEATH OF
THEIR PARTNER AND I WE WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT THIS BILL WILL
ACCOUNT FOR THAT TIME IN
RETROSPECT SO. RESPECTFULLY
ARCHER SUPPORTING THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
CNN QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN WITH.
AND JUST TO CLARIFY YOUR TAKING
THE AMENDMENTS.
YES ABSOLUTELY RETROACTIVE
REFUND PROVISION AND NEAR THE
PRIOR EXCLUSION AND
ADMINISTRATIVE REQUIREMENTS
GIVEN O THE STATE REGISTERED
DOMESTIC PARTNERS.
YES.
LYCOS.
JUST TODD THIS WILL HELP.
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO'VE BY NO
FAULT OF THEIR OUR OWNER BEING
DENIED BENEFITS THAT PEOPLE WHO
ARE IN DOMESTIC PARTNERSHIPS ARE
MARRIED YOU SHOULD BE ABLE TO
ENJOY. AND I URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM ONLY DO
THIS. WE ARE TO PASS THIS
DOESN'T AFFECT A LOT OF PEOPLE
BUT FOR THOSE IT DOES IT IS VERY
IMPORTANT.
NEGLECT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FLOOR WOULD YOU LIKE TO COME UP.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO OPEN
ABSOLUTELY THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR
MEMBERS.
WAS START BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS IN ONE
THING THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THESE AMENDMENTS.
AS WE ALL KNOW CALIFORNIA'S
PRICKLY WITNESS THEM'S.
SOME OF THE MOST DEVASTATING
FIRES AND FIREFIGHTERS ARE
PUTTING THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE
MORE AND MORE TO PROTECT LIVES
AND PROPERTY.
YEAH WILL THE DEMANDS OF THE
FIRE SERVICES ESCALATED MANY
DISTRICTS DO NOT HAVE THE
SUFFICIENT FUNDING TO COVER THE
NECESSARY EXPENSES.
THIS IS LOVE FIREFIGHTERS
EXPRESSLY VOLUNTEERS TO COVER
THE MAJORITY OF THE COSTS
HAVING BEEN A FIREFIGHTER FOR
MANY YEARS I CAN TELL YOU FIRST
HAND HOW MUCH THESE INDIVIDUALS
PUT TO THE PROFESSION.
BECAUSE OF THIS THE FIRING
HISTORY HAS FOUND IT DIFFICULT
TO RECRUIT AND RETRAIN
FIREFIGHTERS AB TWENTY SEVEN
TWENTY SEVEN WOULD PROVIDE. A
PERSONAL INCOME TAX CREDIT FOR
FIREFIGHTERS. UP TO FIFTEEN
HUNDRED DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
QUALIFIED JOB RELAYS EXPENSES X.
SUCH AS TRAINING AND EQUIPMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD AID CURRENT
FIREFIGHTERS IN ENHANCE
RECRUITMENT EFFORTS BY PROVIDING
SENATE TO THOSE WHO WISH TO
SERVE THE COMMUNITY. AND THE
FIRE INDUSTRY.
HERE WITH ME TODAY IS TO TESTIFY
IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL HIS
SHASTA COUNTY SUPERVISOR LESS
BOND.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE
MEMBERS I AM LESS BOSS AS COUNTY
SUPERVISOR CURRENTLY SERVING AS
CHAIRMAN OF OUR BOARD. THE
MAJORITY OF OUR THIRTEEN FIRE
DISTRICTS RELY ON VOLUNTEER
FORCES INCLUDING EIGHTEEN
COMPLETELY VOLUNTEER STATIONS.
SHASTA COUNTY IS A MEMBER OF RC
RC THE RURAL COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES CALIFORNIA. AND
ORGANIZATION OF THIRTY FIVE
RURAL COUNTIES IN THE SPONSOR OF
THIS BILL.
ALL OF OUR COUNTY UTILIZING Y.
UPON SERVICES OF VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTERS.
IN MANY OF OUR FIRE DISTRICTS
RELY ENTIRELY ON VOLUNTEER
EFFORTS.
FOR MEMBERS THIS COMMUNITY USE
THAT THAT MAKE UP THOSE FORCES
THAT PROVIDE CRITICAL PUBLIC
SERVICE.
RESPONDING TO STRUCTURE FIRES
EMERGENCY RESPONSE CALLS AND
OFTEN THE FIRST LINE OF DEFENSE.
ON WILDLAND FIRES IN THEIR OWN
COMMUNITIES.
IT'S BECOME INCREASINGLY
DIFFICULT FOR US.
IN RURAL FIRE DISTRICTS TO
RECRUIT AND RETAIN VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTERS IN SHASTA COUNTY
ALONE WERE DOWN NEARLY ONE
HUNDRED VOLUNTEER FIREFIGHTERS
AND THAT'S OVER THE LAST FIVE
YEAR TIME FRAME. IN MY
DISCUSSIONS WITH OTHER
SUPERVISORS IT'S EVIDENT THAT
MOST OF THE THIRTY FIVE RURAL
COUNTIES HAVE EXPERIENCES SAME
TRENDS.
THAT THIS PROPOSED TAX CREDIT
OF AB TWENTY SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
IS A SMALL RECOGNITION FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS THAT PUT THEIR LIVES
ON THE LINE.
ATTACKED THE LIVES AND
PROPERTIES OF OTHERS WITHIN
THEIR COMMUNITY AND ALSO A IN MY
PERSPECTIVE DESERVE TO HAVE SOME
SORT OF RECOGNITION.
REIMBURSING THEM OR GIVING THEM
A TAX CREDIT FOR SELF PAY COSTS
MITIGATED WITH THAT TAX CREDIT.
SO WITH YOUR ASSISTANCE TO GET
RIGHT TO THE THE PUNCH HERE WITH
YOUR ASSISTANCE WE CAN HELP
REBUILD OUR VOLUNTEER
FIREFIGHTING EFFORTS. SO ON
BEHALF OF SHASTA COUNTY ON
BEHALF OF RC RC. AND AS OF A
FORMER FIRE BOARD MEMBER MYSELF
AND THE FIREFIGHTERS THAT I AM
PROUD TO HAVE REPRESENTED WE
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
AND SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OTHER IN SUPPORT.
AND OPPOSITION.
KENNY.
GREAT.
WHICH FLOOR THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD.
AND TO THE OTHER MEMBERS THE
BODY IN THE COMMITTEE ON MANY
RURAL PARTS OF STATE INCLUDING
MY DISTRICT THERE ARE.
SOME.
.
STATIONS AND ENGINES MANNED BY
ONE PERSON.
AND WITHOUT THE VOLUNTEER FORCE
THAT COMES.
IN PLAYED A ASSIST THOSE
FIREFIGHTERS YOU WILL HAVE A
SINGLE FIREFIGHTER SHOW UP WITH
AN ENGINE. A TWO WAY.
ACCIDENT OR A FIRE CERTAINLY.
WITHOUT THE ABILITY RESOURCES
TO.
TO DEAL WITH THAT SO I
APPRECIATE THOSE VOLUNTEERS ARE
OUT THERE WANT TO SAY.
PUBLICLY ACKNOWLEDGMENT THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK THAT THEY DO IN
THIS SEEMS LIKE A SMALL A TOKEN
OF GRATITUDE THE STATE COULD.
COULD GIVE BACK.
DOCTOR QUIRK.
YES IT'S A THIS IS A TAX CREDIT
IF A PERSON DIDN'T OWE ANY TAX
WOULD DAY GET. TOM MONEY BACK
ANYWAY.
IF THEY DID NOT OWE ANY TAX
YEAH.
TO SAY IT'S A RETIRED PERSON
THEY HAPPEN NOT HAVE EARNINGS.
NOW EXIT QUE.
FIRST OF ALL I'M VERY MUCH
APPRECIATIVE THAT YOU MADE THIS
A CREDIT AS OPPOSED TO
REDUCTION.
DIFFICULTY WITH DEDUCTIONS IS
THAT ONLY THE PEOPLE WHO MAKE A
LOT OF MONEY GET A BENEFIT.
THOE WHO PAY TEN OR TWELVE
PERCENT. AND THE TYPICAL PERSON
WHO PAYS TO WERE THREE PERCENT
GETS ALMOST NOTHING SO I VERY
MUCH APPRECIATE THE WAY OF
STRUCTURED THIS.
I KNOW STAFF HERE IN THE CHAIR
OF FACT YOU TO TAKE A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS.
AND.
I'D LIKE TO KNOW.
WHAT DOES AMENDMENTS ARE THAT
WHALER WON'T BE TAKEN?
RATING GUESS WHERE I AM SO IT'S
SHORTENED THE CREDIT WINDOW TO
FIVE YEARS AND SEVEN NINE.
OKAY.
CLARIFIED THAT THE CREDIT ONLY
APPLIES TO QUALIFIED
FIREFIGHTERS IN CALIFORNIA.
OKAY.
I IT LOWERS THE CREDIT
PERCENTAGE FOR THE PROFESSIONAL
FIREFIGHTERS TO THIRTY FIVE
PERCENT THE PERCENTAGE REMAINS
THE SAME FOR VOLUNTEERS SO WE
WILL BURGER HAVING A HIGHER
CREDIT TO THE THOSE WHO
VOLUNTEER THAN THOSE ARE WHO ARE
PROFOUND QUE SO IT'S THE SAME.
SO.
IN MY CITY WHERE THERE ONLY
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THEY
COULD GET THAT IS THERE A GOOD.
DEFINITION OF WHAT TRAINING IS.
ARE GOOD DEFINITIONAL TRANCE.
I MEANWHILE THERE'S A WHEN IT
COMES TO TRAINING IN THE FIRE
SERVICE THERE'S MANY SCOPES
WHICH THE FIRE SERVICE TRAINS
AND A LOT OF THOSE WE HAVE A
TRAINING OFFICER THAT TO PUT
TOGETHER'S TRAINEES FOR. VARIOUS
IN THE STATE MANDATES HOW MANY
HOURS WE GOTTA PUT INTO
PARTICULAR TRAINING AND THAT'S
THAT'S MANDATED BY THE STATE.
SO YES THERE IS A DEFINITION
ISSUE IT WOULD JUST BE STATE
MANDATED TRAINING IS THAT
CORRECT.
WELL YES AND NO I MEAN I THINK
THIS STATE THERE'S A LOT OF
DIFFERENT.
AREAS THE STATE TRAINING CAN BE
TAKEN INTO WHEN IT COMES TO EMS
TRAIN MERGE THE MEDICAL SERVICE
TRAIN THERE'S A AT THE VAST
AREA.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT INDIVIDUAL
DEPARTMENTS LIKE IN OUR AREA WE
HAVE A LOT OF MASSIVE AND.
FREEWAYS SO WE DO A LOT OF AUTO
EDUCATION SO WE TEND TO FOCUS
HEAVILY ON THAT AS OPPOSED TO A
STRUCTURE FIRE FIGHTING BECAUSE
THAT'S OUR BREAD AND BUTTER.
NAM.
WELL WHAT I'M ALRIGHT SO WHERE
DID IF WOULDN'T INCLUDE EMS
TRAINING ABSOLUTELY OKAY. WOULD
INCLUDE TRANSPORTATION TO AND
FROM TRAINING.
.
I WOULD SAY NO. OKAY.
BOB WELL PERHAPS YOU CAN JUST
CHECK AND AND MAKE SURE THAT
THAT'S FOR SURE LIMITED IF YOU
LOOK AT THE ANALYSIS ON A. ON
PAGE FIVE IT SHE WROTE GOES
THROUGH WHAT NEEDS TO BE
CLARIFIED WHAT EQUIPMENT LIKE
TRAINING SO THE AUTHOR WILL WORK
ON THAT. IN THE NEXT CAN ONLY
OKAY FINE.
THAT'S WHAT I'D READ WHITE
REASON I WAS ASKING THE QUESTION
EVER GONNA LEAVE AUTHOR CHANCE
TO WORK ON THAT'S FINE I'LL BE
VOTING FOR THE BILL THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE EXPECT
LASTLY I HOPE WE ARE QUORUM WE
WOULD LOVE TO VOTE.
WE CAN ACQUIRE.
AND ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY SEVEN OR TEN WOULD
YOU LIKE TO COME UP.
YOU MAY OPEN.
THANK YOU MEDICARE.
HERE
.
MADAM CHAIR COMMITTEE MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. UP
FIRST LIKE TO START OFF SAYING
THAT I'M CITING ALL THE
COMMITTEES AMENDMENTS I WANT TO
THANK ME STAFF WORKING. ON THIS
BILL.
AB TWO FIVE NINE ZERO WOULD
EXEMPT GROSS INCOME TAX FOR
FOR ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY MEMBERS
THAT RESIDE IN CALIFORNIA.
MORE SPECIFICALLY IT WOULD SEND
THE PAY THAT IS EARNED WHILE THE
SERVICE NEVER HOURS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE I APOLOGIZE IF IT'S
POSSIBLE AND SHARE FOR WOULD
TAKE AB THREE ONE TWO EIGHT
FIRST.
THE YEAH STABLE VETERANS SERVICE
TAUGHT CREDIT. SO A MOVE TO ITEM
EIGHT A. B. THIRTY ONE TWENTY
EIGHT
THANK YOU MADAM FIVE EIGHT.
I APOLOGIZE. AGAIN LIKE TO START
BY SAYING THAT SOMETHING OVER
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
AB THREE WANT TO A WOULD PROVIDE
A TAX CREDIT FOR DISABLED
VETERANS TO HELP OFFSET THE COST
OF OWNING A SERVICE ANIMAL.
VETERANS FACE SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGES WHEN THEY RE ENTRY
CIVILIAN LIFE
WHY CAN THE STRUCTURE AND
DISCIPLINE THAT BECOME
ACCUSTOMED TO THE MILITARY.
OFTENTIMES A RETURN HOME FEELING
DISCONNECTED EVEN FROM CLOSE
FRIENDS AND FAMILY.
ACCORDING TO THE DEPARTMENT OF
VETERANS AFFAIRS ESTIMATE TWENTY
TWO VETERANS COMMIT SUICIDE
EVERYDAY.
ONE POWERFUL TWO WE HAVE TO
COMBAT THE SUICIDE RATE AMONG
VETERANS.
IS THE HEALING POWER OF SERVICE
ANIMALS.
DESCRIBED AS BEING LIFESAVERS
FOR VETERANS SUFFERING FROM
EMOTIONAL PHYSICAL AND
PSYCHOLOGICAL DISABILITIES.
SERVICE ANIMALS PROVIDE
ASSISTANCE IN A VARIETY OF
CAPACITIES FROM SOMETHING
ENDANGERS OPEN DOOR.
TO SOMETHING MORE SERIOUS A
SUMMING ASSISTANCE IN A MEDICAL
EMERGENCY.
RECOGNIZING THE POSITIVE IMPACT
SERVICE ANIMALS MAKE ON THE
LIVES OF MILITARY VETERANS.
SERVICE SEVERAL NON PROFITS
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY HAVE
FORMED TO CONNECT VETERANS WITH
SERVICE ANIMALS.
UNFORTUNATELY IT'S COST ME A
BURDENSOME MILITARY VETERANS
MANY OF WHOM STRUGGLE TO FIND
EMPLOYMENT WHEN THEY GET OUT OF
SERVICE.
I AM JOINED TODAY BY ONE OF
THESE NON PROFITS HERE WITH ME
TO TESTIFY IS KEVIN CAMERON FROM
ALPHA CANINE.
CAMERON.
MEDICARE COMMITTEE.
ONES CAN CAN ON THE CHIEF
EXECUTIVE OFFICER OF OFF CANINE.
WERE SERVICE ARE TRAINED
ORGANIZATION LOOKING HERE IN
SACRAMENTO.
WITH THE PRIMARY MISSION OF
PROVIDING POSTTRAUMATIC STRESS
SERVICE DOGS TO VETERANS FIRST
RESPONDERS. ABUSED WOMEN AND
KIDS.
I'M ALSO LPC SEE I TRAUMA
THERAPIST CURRENTLY SPECIALISING
ANALISIS THERAPIES.
I'M ALSO THIRTY YEAR MILITARY
DECORATED COMBAT THAT MY JOB IN
THE US ARMY WAS IS A MILITARY
WORKING DOG HAMMERING
KILLMASTER.
THE IF YOU SEE A AS OF THIS YEAR
ESTIMATES ACOSTA PET OWNERSHIP
SPECIFICALLY FOR A DOG TO BE
BETWEEN SEVENTEEN HUNDRED AND
TWO THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR.
AS FOR TYPICAL HOUSE PET.
SERVICE DOGS INCURRING EVEN
GREATER COST.
UNLIKE BASIC HOUSE PETS THE
SURGEON WAS COSTLY BEING WORK
AND OFTEN REQUIRES ADDITIONAL
MEDICAL CARE HIGHER QUALITY FOOD
EXTRA GEAR AND EQUIPMENT TO
ALLOW FOR INCLEMENT WEATHER AND
TO ENSURE THE HEALTH WILL BE IN
THE ANIMAL.
THESE COSTS. DO NOT INCLUDE THE
EQUIPMENT THE CANINE AND THEY
HAVE THEIR NEED NOR THE COST THE
ANIMAL ITSELF.
THE NATIONAL AVERAGE STEVEN TINA
WHEN THESE DOGS CAN BE IN EXCESS
OF THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS.
NO LEASE COST THE CITY WITH THE
ANIMALS ARE COVERED BY INSURANCE
IS.
UPON TO INCLUDE THE CANE AND THE
TRAINING AND EQUIPMENT MORE CARE
THE ANIMAL.
THIS BILL ADDRESS WE POSITIVELY
IMPACT ALLEGED MANY EVER WANTED
SERVICE MEMBERS AND OTHERS
RECORDING SERVICE ANIMALS IN
ORDER TO FUNCTION THE WORLD THEY
PUT THEIR LIVES ON TO PROTECT.
MANY PEOPLE LIVE ON FIXED
INCOMES DUE TO THEIR
DISABILITIES AND OFTEN HAVE
LIMITED ABILITY TO WORK.
IN A SITUATION WHERE DISABILITY
REQUIRES A PERSON TO LIVE WITHIN
A LIMITED MEANS.
ANY TYPE OF FINANCIAL BREAKS OF
THIS TYPE CAN WE LEAD TO A
DRASTIC IMPROVEMENT ON THEIR
QUALITY OF LIFE.
GENTLY MEDICAL DEVICES OF.
AND MEDICALLY NECESSARY
EQUIPMENT ARE COVERED.
BY INSURANCES AS WELL AS TAX
CREDITS SERVICE DOGS CURRENTLY
ARE NOT THIS BILL WOULD BE A
STEP IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION
PROVIDE ANY FINANCIAL QUALITY
BETWEEN. OTHER MEDICAL
DISABILITIES AND THOSE WHO
REQUIRE THE USE OF SERVICE.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
HI GOOD EVENING OR GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS MAYES CASE YOUR CAR
ALLEGE DIRECTOR FOR POV VICE
CHAIR FIONA MA HERE DAY IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL AND THANK
YOU TO THE OTHER FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD.
I COULD HAVE. GOOD AFTERNOON
CAROLING UNDER THE STATE HUMANE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE CALIFORNIA ANIMAL CONTROL
DIRECTORS ASSOCIATION FOR ALL
THE REASONS THAT THE AUTHOR
OUTLINED RESCUE FOR ABOUT TAKING
CARE.
MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS AND
ACCORDING TO THE CALIFORNIA
TALKS THAT REFORM ASSOCIATION I
APOLOGIZE THE CITY OF TREES IS
TAKING ITS TOLL ON ME TODAY.
WE ARE NOT WITHSTANDING ANY
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS THAT MAY
COME FROM THIS COMMITTEE.
CURRENTLY IN OPPOSE UNLESS
AMENDED ON THIS MEASURE ON OUR
LARGEST CONCERN WE DON'T OPPOSE
THE CONCEPT ITSELF CERTAINLY IS
THAT ULTIMATELY THE INTENDED
BENEFICIARIES WOULD NOT BENEFIT
FROM THE BILL AS IT'S IN PRINT.
CERTAINLY CALIFORNIA TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION HAS LONG HAD A
POSITION THAT DIRECT
EXPENDITURES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
PREFERABLE TO A TAX EXPENDITURE
BUT I BELIEVE THERE WERE A
COUPLE RECOMMENDATIONS MADE. ON
EVEN IN THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
BOTH IN REGARDS TO. WHETHER THEY
SHOULD BE A NON REFUNDABLE OR
REFUNDABLE CREDIT GET CREDIT
EXCUSE ME.
VERSES ENSURING THAT AND THERE
WAS SOME SORT OF AGGREGATE
AMOUNT OR CAP PLEASED ON. ON THE
TAX EXPENDITURE AND SO ABSENT
SOME OF THOSE CHANGES WHICH CAN
VERY WELL MAY COME OUT TODAY IN
THIS COMMITTEE WERE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
THINKING.
HAVE QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
PART QUIRK.
BOB I THOUGHT THAT ABOUT THE
BILL ASSEMBLY MEMBER YEAH I I
HAVE THE SAME.
CONCERNS THE TAX REFORM
ASSOCIATION DOES I WOULD PREFER
GRANT PROGRAM. AND I TYPICALLY.
THEY I'M.
AND THE PRICE HERE IS QUITE HIGH
SIXTY MILLION DOLLARS.
THE PRICE IN THE PREVIOUS ONE
WHICH WAS RACIALLY THIRTEEN AND
WAS REDUCED CONSIDERABLY BY THE
AMENDMENTS.
I I JUST THINK THAT THIS IS JUST
TOO HIGH A PRICE AND. I WOULD
PREFER THIS GO THROUGH THE
BUDGET AS A.
THE PROGRAM OUGHT TO SUPPLY
MONEY FOR THOSE WHO NEED AS
OPPOSED TO A TAX CREDIT THANK
YOU.
ANY FURTHER COMMENTS ON THE
BILL.
BY MEMBERS.
SEEING NONE SOMEWAY MEMBER
CHALLENGE LIKE CLOSE.
MY RESPECT ESPERANDO.
ARE YOU EXPECT ARE YOU
ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS.
I'M OPEN TO LOOKING AT THIS NOW
ON CURRENT TIME AND.
I'VE ACCEPT ALL THE AMENDMENTS
THAT YOU HAVE ACCEPTED IT NOT
HER AMENDMENTS MY AM EMBARRASSED
YOU'RE OKAY. SO WE'LL GO THROUGH
THEM REALLY QUICKLY WE EXPAND
THE SENSE THAT TO TEN YEARS IT'S
CURRENTLY AS YOU RECOMMENDED YOU
ASKED FOR THREE.
I THINK WE SHOULD DO MORE FOR A
BETTER AND SO.
ARE WILL ON THIS COMMITTEE WE
WILL BE CONSISTENT BUT FOR
VETERANS ITEM FOR VETERANS WILL
MOVE TO TENURE SUNSETS.
I'LL EXPAND THE CLASS APPALLED
BY DOCTOR INCLUDE GUIDE DOGS AND
SIGNAL DOGS.
RESTRICT THE ABILITY OF TAXPAYER
TO DOUBLE DIP USING THE SAME DOG
MAINTENANCE EXPENSE FOR THIS
CREDIT AND CURRENTLY AVAILABLE
MEDICAL EXPENSE DEDUCTION.
OKAY SO WHEN WE HAVE A QUORUM IT
WILL BE A DO PASS TO
PREPARATIONS WITH THE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
RIGHT WING ITEMS THREE AB TWENTY
FIVE NINETY.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
AGAIN FOR AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY
EIGHT A LIGHT SURFACE I AM
ACCEPTING ALL THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS I WANT TO THANK
COMMITTEE STAFFER WORKING ON
THIS BILL.
AB TWENTY FIVE NINE WHAT SOME
GROSS INCOME TAX FOR THE ACTIVE
DUTY MILITARY MEMBERS THAT
RESIDE IN CALIFORNIA. MORE
SPECIFICALLY IT LOOKS AT THE PAY
THAT IS ARE AND WHAT A SERVICE
MEMBER IS ON ORDERS OUTSIDE OF
CALIFORNIA FOR EXAMPLE.
IF THE DUTY ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
MEMBER IS ON DIRECT ORDERS FROM
THE MILITARY FOR CONSECUTIVE
NINETY DAYS OR LONGER. THE PAY
THAT THE EARNED WHILE OUT OF
STATE WILL BE EXEMPT.
FROM CALIFORNIA STATE INCOME
TAXES.
CURRENTLY MEMBERS OF THE
MILITARY WHO ARE NOT DEPLOYED TO
COMBAT ZONE ARE NOT EXEMPT FROM
INCOME TAX.
WHERE AS IF THEY ARE IN COMBAT
SO THEY WOULD GET A TAX
EXEMPTION?
THE MEMBERS ARE SENT TO OTHER
AREAS OF THE WORLD ARE STILL
PERFORMING THE DUTIES
TO PROTECT OUR COUNTRY. AND
AREN'T ABLE TO BENEFIT THE
SERVICES THAT STATE INCOME TAX
PROVIDES FOR CALIFORNIA.
AB TWENTY FOUR NINETY WOULD LOWN
CALIFORNIANS TO FALL EXAMPLE OF
OTHER STATES.
I HAVE ADDITIONAL TAX EXEMPTIONS
FOR ACTIVE DUTY MILITARY
MEMBERS.
THIS CLOSE MY REMARKS.
WHEN DOZENS OR.
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE ARTWORK CHO.
ITS PATENTED.
NOT AT ALL NOT.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS WITH MANY.
JUDGE CLOSE.
I RESPECT AYE FRAZIER AYE VOTE
AND WE HAVE A WE HAVE A.
.
QUORUM THE ONLY LIMIT IS TO ADD
AGAIN THE TENURE SUNSET. TO THE
BILL ITS MILITARY
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR.
THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ALL BEGIN BY ACCEPTING
THE COMMITTEE'S RECOMMENDED
MEHMET'S
WHICH WILL ONE HAD A FIVE YEAR
SUNSET TO THE BILL TO. ADD
LANGUAGE TO PROHIBIT AN
INDIVIDUAL FROM TAKING BOTH AT
ABOUT THE LINE DEDUCTION ANIMAL.
MISCELLANEOUS ITEMIZED DEDUCTION
THE SAME.
FOR THE SAME MEMBERSHIP DUES
SO TIGHT YOU FOR THOSE.
SUGGESTIONS ALL BE HAPPY TO
ACCEPT THOSE AB TWENTY FIVE
SEVENTY SEVEN WILL CREATE AN
ABOVE THE LINE DEDUCTION TO
ENSURE THAT ALL TAXPAYERS.
REGARDLESS OF THEIR INCOME
BRACKET WILL BE ABLE TO RECEIVE
THE BENEFIT OF DEDUCTING THE
COST OF THE UNION MEMBERSHIP
DUES FROM THEIR ANNUAL GROSS
INCOME.
UNDER EXISTING STATE AND FEDERAL
LAW TAXPAYERS ARE PROVIDED THE
OPTION TO CLAIM THE STANDARD
DEDUCTION OR TO ITEMIZE THEIR
DEDUCTIONS.
EXISTING STATE LAW ALLOWS THE
DIRECTION OF UNION DUES AND
INITIATION FEES ONLY FOR FILERS
WHO ITEMIZE TO THE EXTENT THAT A
FILERS MISCELLANEOUS ITEMIZED
DEDUCTIONS EXCEED TWO PERCENT OF
THEIR ADJUSTED GROSS INCOME.
AGAIN OR POINT OUT THIS BENEFIT
IS PROVIDED ONLY TO TAXPAYERS
WHO DO NOT CLAIM THE STANDARD
DEDUCTION AND WHO INSTEAD CHOOSE
TO ITEMIZE DEDUCTIONS.
PREVIOUS IRS DATA ILLUSTRATES
THE TAXPAYERS AND HIGHER INCOMES
ARE MORE LIKELY TO ITEMIZE
DEDUCTIONS.
THOSE WITH LOWER INCOMES ARE
MORE LIKELY TO OPT FOR THE
STANDARD DEDUCTION.
SEVENTY EIGHT PERCENT OF
HOUSEHOLDS WITH INCOMES BETWEEN
A HUNDRED THOUSAND TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ITEMIZED
DEDUCTIONS.
NINETY THREE PERCENT OF THOSE
HOUSEHOLDS WITH INCOMES OVER TWO
HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
CONVERSELY ONLY TWENTY ONE
PERCENT OF HOUSEHOLDS WITH
INCOMES BETWEEN TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FIFTY THOUSAND ITEMIZED
DEDUCTIONS THAT'S ONLY ABOUT ONE
IN FIVE MEMBERS.
ALLOWING INDIVIDUALS TO DEDUCT
FROM HIS OR HER GROSS INCOME THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY PAID TO
MEMBERSHIP DUES TO LABOR
ORGANIZATION. WILL BOTH REDUCE
THE TAX BURDEN FACED BY LOWER
AND MIDDLE INCOME TAXPAYERS WHO
DO NOT ITEMIZE THEIR RETURNS.
AND INSURE THAT ALL TAXPAYERS
RECEIVE ECRU BENEFITS FOR THE
SAME ON REIMBURSABLE EMPLOYMENT
ACTIVITIES.
AB TWENTY FIVE SEVENTY SEVEN TO
SUPPORT BY MANY OF OUR LABOR
ALLIES INCLUDING INTERNATIONAL
LONGSHOREMEN WAREHOUSE UNION.
THE PEACE OFFICERS RESEARCH
ASSOCIATION CALIFORNIA THE
CALIFORNIA TEAMSTERS PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COUNCIL AMONGST OTHERS
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY REQUEST
YOUR ARRIVAL HERE TODAY.
WHEN ASSISTANCE FOR.
BEFORE WE DO THAT.
WELL WE HAVE A QUORUM.
YES.
CRITICAL THE WORLD.
WHERE I SIX CAN YOU SIR?
WELL HERE.
ALLEN.
BONTA. CHU GRAY.
I HEAR MCCARTY MELENDEZ MULLIN
QUIRK.
WE DID IT KATE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MADAM CHAIR MATT BROWN.
FROM BROWNING GUSMAN HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE TEAMSTERS EIGHTEEN
YEAR OLD LONG CHARM AND. UTILITY
WORKERS ENGINEERS SCIENTISTS OF
CALIFORNIA AND I OF P. T. LOCAL
TWENTY ONE WE SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
COMMENSURATE RYAN SHERMAN WITH
THE RIVERSIDE SHERIFF'S
ASSOCIATION ONE SPORT AS WELL.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M STEPHANIE
DOUBT ALOG WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WHAT WE ARE
BOARD DOES NOT YET HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BUT.
BILL WE THINK THIS IS AN
IMPORTANT CONVERSATION HAVE.
AND WE DO SUPPORT AYE VOTE.
WITNESSES OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS AND COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
NETWORK.
YEAH MY PROBLEM WITH THIS
YEAR'S.
SOMEBODY WHO WORKS IN A HOTEL.
AS YOU MAY WELL GETS THIRTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A YEAR WILL GET
VIRTUALLY NO.
ADVANTAGE FROM THIS
SOMEBODY WORKS FOR A HIGH TECH
COMPANY LIKE I DID AND MAKES A
HUNDRED AND FIFTY THOUSAND A
YEAR. NASA SPOUSE TO MAKE
SOMETHING SIMILAR WILL GATHER
TWELVE TEN OR TWELVE PERCENT
BENEFIT.
.
I JUST DON'T THINK THIS IS FAIR
SO I'D BUY WILL NOT BE
SUPPORTING IT.
I'M NOT SURE YOU'VE READ THE
BILL AND FUNNY MISTER QUIRK
FOUND.
THIS ACTUALLY.
CURRENT LAW HAS A.
DISTORTION EFFECT IN THE MANNER
YOU DESCRIBED.
AS I SAID IN MY COMMENTS.
INCOMES THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND AND EIGHTY
PERCENT OF THOSE INDIVIDUALS
CURRENTLY TAKE THIS. UNDER THE
CURRENT SYSTEM IT'S ONLY THE
LOWER INCOME FOLKS ONE FACTOR.
NOT GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY TO
HAVE SOME TAX BENEFIT FOR THE
EXACT SAME A YOU KNOW EMPLOYMENT
EXPENSE ACTUALLY IS NOT THE CASE
BECAUSE HE'S MISCELLANEOUS
DEDUCTIONS CAN ONLY BE USED. IF
THERE SOMETHING LIKE I'VE
FORGOTTEN THE NUMBER BUT IT'S
AROUND TEN PERCENT OF THE INCOME
SO VERY FEW PEOPLE END UP TAKING
THAT AND HIGH INCOME PEOPLE EVEN
LESS OUR.
SINCE THE UNION DO SEEM TO BE
SIMILAR KNOW THE DIFFICULTY I
HAVE IS INSTEAD OF A TAX CREDIT.
YOU'RE GIVING A DEDUCTION IN
INCOME.
ALRIGHT SO IF YOU HAVE MAKING
THIRTY THOUSAND A YEAR.
AND YOU'RE PAYING A COUPLE
PERCENT.
YOU BET AND YOU PAID A THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN DUES YOU'RE GETTING
TWENTY DOLLARS BACK.
IF YOU'RE MAKING THREE HUNDRED
THOUSAND A YEAR.
AND YOU SUBTRACT FROM THE INCOME
YOU GET TWELVE PERCENT BACK.
OR A HUNDRED AND TWENTY DOLLARS
SO THAT MEANS A LOW INCOME
PERSON IS GETTING THE TWENTY
DOLLAR BENEFIT. HIGH INCOME
PERSON GETS A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY.
NEVER TAX CREDIT I COULD
UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW WHAT THAT'S
FINE.
THEN YOU'RE GIVING EVERYBODY
THE SAME AMOUNT BUT IT WHEN IT'S
IT DEDUCTION FROM INCOME. COULD
THE AMOUNT YOU GET DEPENDS UPON
WHAT THE PERCENT YOU'RE PAYING
IN TAXES IS AND THAT'S JUST MUCH
HIGHER FOR HIGH INCOME
INDIVIDUALS.
WE HAVE A PROGRESSIVE TAX.
AS WE SHOULD AND YOU'RE YOU'RE
TRYING TO MAKE IT LESS
PROGRESSIVE BY GIVING PEOPLE
BREAKS TO OF HIGH INCOME SO YOUR
ARGUMENT IS BETTER TO KEEP THE
TWENTY DOLLARS AND GOVERNMENT'S
POCKET THEN HANDED BACK TO THE
LOAN COUNT I WOULD I WOULD
SUPPORT A TAX CREDIT.
FOR CERTAIN AMOUNT BUT I CAN'T
THINK A CORD A YEAH A CHANGE IN
IN THAT DEDUCTIONS OR FROM
INCOME.
I COULD SUPPORT A TAX CREDIT
BECAUSE THEN EVERYBODY COULD
PRESUMABLY GET THE SAME AMOUNT.
YOU WOULDN'T BE GIVING SIX SERVE
FIVE OR SIX TIMES AS MUCH TO
WEALTHY PEOPLE IS TO POOR
PEOPLE.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THANK ALL OF ON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
QUIRK AT IS THAT SOMETHING YOU
WOULD CONSIDER FOR THE FUTURE OR
IF YOU HAVE YOU. THAT SOME YOU
THOUGHT THROUGH AND AND THINK
THAT IT'S CLEAR THE WAY IT IS I
THINK I'M CERTAINLY OPEN TO
THEM.
MY POINT IS WHERE EVERYBODY
OUGHT TO RECEIVE SOME BENEFIT
FROM AYE SOME POINT EXPENSES AND
UNDER CURRENT LAW THAT DOESN'T
OCCUR. A MISSED APPROACH POINT
SEEMS TO BE IT DOESN'T OCCUR IN
THIS BILL TO THE EXTENT IT LIKE.
I SEE IT.
ALTHOUGH AS I UNDERSTOOD EVEN
HIS QUESTION THE TAXPAYER STILL
BETTER OFF.
AFTER THIS BILL PASSED THAN THEY
ARE. CURRENTLY I GREW THAT I
UNDERSTAND YOUR POINT TWO OKAY
THANK YOU MISTER RIGHT.
IF YOU WOULD AGREE TO CONSIDER
A TAX CREDIT AS OPPOSED TO
DEDUCTION FROM INCOME I'D BE
WILLING TO VOTE TO GET IT OUT OF
THE COMMITTEE NOW AND RESERVE MY
VOTE ON THE FLOOR A.
WOULD YOU CONSIDER THAT
ABSOLUTELY SIR I APPRECIATE THAT
THAT CONSIDERATION MY CASH
CERTAINLY CONSIDER WORKING WITH
YOU TO IMPROVE THE BILL SO THAT
WE CAN NOW MAKE THIS MORE
EQUITABLE. OKAY THEN I'LL BE
VOTING I THANK YOU THAT YOU.
IT'S GREAT ANYONE ELSE QUESTIONS
AND COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE
NINE WOULD DO LIKE CLOSE.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO.
A SUMMARY WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE.
I THANK YOU FOR THOUGH LIVELY
DISCUSSION RESPECTFULLY ASK YOU
I'M.
AND THANK YOU AND WE HAVE A
QUORUM SO THIS IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED APPROPRIATIONS NOT THE
CREDIT THAT IS A CONVERSATION
THAT YOU ALL WILL HAVE MOVING
FORWARD.
MOVE THE BILL SECOND.
CORD WINDS OF BILL MISTER BONTA
SECONDS WITHOUT WE WILL TAKE A
VOTE.
MACHINIST WHO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR.
BURKE AYE BROUGH.
WELL I ALLEN. ALLEN NOT VOTING
BONTA. BONTA AYE CHIU.
CHIU AYE GRAY AYE GRAY AYE
MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
YES PLEASE.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK OF.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
MOVING TO FILE ITEM THREE AB
TWENTY FIVE NINETEEN.
OKAY THAT'S A DUTY TO.
HER HOLD ON.
YEAH YOU CAN START. WITH NUMBER
THREE.
RIGHT IT YOUR. ITEM NUMBER THREE
AB TWENTY FIVE NINETY.
IT'S ACTIONS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
WE MOTION AND.
ITEM NUMBER THREE ITEM NUMBER
THREE.
THE MOTION BY BROE'S SECOND BY
ALLEN.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS BURKE. BURKE
I'VE WORLD.
THROW AYE ALLEN. ALLEN AYE
BONTA.
BONTA RHS YOU. CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
LINDA THAYER AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK. QUIRK NOW THAT
BILL IS OUT THAT PILLOWS OUT
MOVING TO FILE ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY SIX SIXTY THREE WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
THE BILL.
MOTION BY DOCTOR QUIRK SECOND
MIND MR BONTA.
THE ACTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MUCH LESS DO PASSES AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS BURKE AYE VERB
AYE BROUGH. GROW AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN NOT VOTING BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHIU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK BY BIRTH I.
THAT GOES OUT.
MOVING FILE ITEM FIVE AB TWENTY
SEVEN TWENTY SEVEN.
AS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
AFFECTING.
A MISTER BROWN LOOSENESS ROUNDS
AGAINST.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND IT TOO
APPROPRIATIONS PER AYE BURKE AYE
RO. ROW AYE ALLEN.
ELLEN AYE BONTA. BONTA AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GRAY. GRAY AYE MCCARTY
MELINDA'S.
LINDA'S AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE RIGHT
ABILITIES OUT.
THAT GOES OUT MOVING TO FILE
ITEM SIX AB TWENTY SEVEN
THIRTEEN.
MOTION BY BROE'S SECOND BY
ALLEN.
TERMINATION IS NONE.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR NOT VOTING
BURKE NOT VOTING BRO. BRO AYE
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE BONTA.
WANT TO HURRY TO. CHIU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY MELENDEZ.
LINDA'S AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN NOT VOTING QUIRK I.
QUIRK I.
IT'S A.
THAT GOES OUT LIVING VIOLENCE
SEVEN AB TWENTY NINE THIRTY
EIGHT
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS MADE A MOTION AND
A SECOND.
SECOND FLOOR MISTER BREMER THE
BILL MISTER BONTA SECOND.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS IS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
BURKE I BURKE I BRILL. ROLE I
ALLEN. ALLEN AYE BONTA. BONTA
AYE CHU. CHU AYE GRAY. GRAY AYE
MCCARTY MELINDA'S.
MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE
THE BILL'S HOUSE WE IMPLEMENT A
FILE ITEM EIGHT AB THIRTY ONE
TWENTY EIGHT.
ALLEN IS A BILL PRO SECONDS.
MUCH DO PASSED HIM AS A MEMBER
TO APPROPRIATIONS.
MOTION HAS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS FOR AYE AYE BURKE
AYE BRILL.
GROW AYE ALLEN.
ALLEN AYE BONTA.
BONTA AYE CHU. CHU AYE GRAY.
GRAY AYE MCCARTY. MELINDA'S.
MELINDA'S AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE QUIRK NO BURKE NOW
THAT BILLS.
DO YOU. THINK IF YOU.
ACCORDING.
WORK.
ABOVE WHERE IT.
MISS MELINDA'S DID YOU.
SANTIAGO